i feel like in my household my opinion
is not valid
and it will never be valid as long as i
live my parents will yell at me they'll
get mad at me and we'll get into like
such large arguments it's even gotten to
the point of one time where i've gotten
into arguments my parents were like
you're gonna have to move out if you
don't like agree with these things
[Music]
i've sent or received nudes
three answer two one
go girl
i mean like
if one day i want to get a certain job
or go into
a political office i just don't ever
want to have somebody to hold that
against me even when people send me
nudes i'm like i didn't
necessarily need that like wait when
they're just you know
are we saying nudes nudes
saying news
i don't send nudes because i just do
things on social media i want to pursue
acting
i feel like my body is a temple you
gotta pay to see it if at least
same as daniel said it can come back and
bite you i'm just scared
revenge porn is very real and i think
most women or women adjacent people
have received um unsolicited
pics as like a bisexual person and kind
of just being in like
a world that's hyper already and it
sucks because that's kind of like the
age of social media and like lgbtq youth
is that
pretty much like they have to seek
validation online that's like really
like the way to do it
i agree exactly with what makai said i
mean it is like the form of validation
now like sending nudes is love
but it just makes me just wanna yeah
this makes me just want to jump over it
because i feel like i'm in the wrong
area
you know we're gonna go here if you like
they should respect your values if you
don't want to send nudes and if they if
not like
it's pretty clear to me that they're
just using me for my body nudes has a
lot to do with appearance
and putting a lot of value on how you
appear can just just sometimes be
damaging
to piggyback off that it's really
important too like when you're growing
up no matter like your body type or how
you look
everyone has like beauty in them so it's
important to love your body and love
like how you look because like girl
that's your body like flaunt what you
got boo
that validation needs to come from
within not from other people because
like i know i'm sexy i don't even
know i'm sexy so um period poo
is that going in skinny jeans
are out of style three
two one go
yeah i don't know it was just the era of
the time it was like rock was like
you know pop rock lots of skinny jeans
and then turned into like ripped jeans i
think pants are getting bigger i don't
know if it's because like
maybe we're shifting more towards like
androgyny i just i'm over here because i
think that skinny jeans i don't like
them and i wouldn't wear them because i
also have like chicken legs so like
that's not happening for me they're out
of styler in style
the question was skinny jeans are out of
style oh so i'm saying that they are in
style
yeah skinny jeans oh no they're out of
style i recently bought my like first
pair of like
bag your jeans kind of like what he's
wearing and i was like blown away
honestly like
there's so much space you don't have to
worry about it like bunching up and
stuff like
there's yeah i don't know why we ever
stuck with skinny jeans to begin with
i think the whole skinny jeans side part
thing is generational politics that are
trying to like
distract us from what we actually
disagree about like nobody
actually cares about the skinny jeans
and middle parts like millennials please
stop making songs about it it's not that
deep
i get my news from youtube
three two one go
i chose somewhat disagree because i try
not to just you know stay on youtube
because it can
be a lot of disinformation but i also
feel like
you know i follow a lot of political
youtubers and i feel like their
perspectives are different than what's
on the mainstream because like
three corporations own all of the media
social news twitter hundred percent
easily but like if it's like some
political stuff i have like
subscriptions to like
new york times even fox and stuff just
that i get perspective from everyone and
i tend to go ahead and like focus more
on like the journalism
stuff and youtube is like the headlines
but i don't click the video and like
deliberately watch it until i've known
the facts the ability of twitter to get
you know
opinions out there from people who
aren't political pundits
um is really valuable and you know when
when big things happen
twitter usually hears about it first i
feel like it kind of just comes down to
like a media literacy thing and it's
something that like
our generation and further generations
are gonna have to face we haven't been
in this era where there's like which
what sarah was saying about like the
democratized way of social media where
like everyone can say information
we're like in this new era where we
pretty much have to learn how to
decipher which
is valuable and valid information what's
not and like as
social media continues to grow i feel
like we're just gonna keep becoming more
literate and i feel like we should be
taught this in schools
we're a whole new era like we grew up
with like tablets and laptops whereas in
like previous generations didn't
which allows us obviously to have more
diverse opinions but i think that should
be taught in school as well do your guys
parents ever just call you and be like
did you know this happened you're like
yeah it happened like
five hours ago and you were like did you
just find out now it's usually fake news
with my mom
oh my gosh usually fake news my mom she
gets too much from facebook literally
she calls me she's like
about this like mom she's like is yeah
like my mom when she was on instagram
she just was like she was seeing the
wrong stuff and then she was like
you know the vaccine those microchips
and i was like mom i think it's also
important to think about like
why people believe that like yeah it's
like stupid and it's funny to make fun
of but like
people are afraid of like you know
really rich people
who are going to be like controlling a
lot of stuff without
you know democratic elections and
without any
accountability and it makes sense that
people would feel like
you know i don't really know if i can
trust the government
my parents and i agree on political and
social issues
three two one go
[Music]
my parents like raised me again on the
whole thing of like look at every single
side
and i guess it didn't go necessarily
their way but at the same time like
sometimes it ends up being a wreck but
like whenever it's a wreck we come back
and we're like i see your point
but here's what i think and here's why
loaded with facts not just like oh i
think this because this and this and
this x and x and said
no it's because it's a percentage this
is a statistic that i'm pointing out
honestly i used to try and like show
them a different perspective
and like have an open conversation but
like i'm kind of at the point now where
it's like you know what let's just not
talk about it it's probably for the best
you know my parents always say to me
like you pay attention to politics more
than we do and we like learn from you
and sometimes we get into little
arguments that can be
a good like way to sort of inform each
other because obviously they have more
experience like
historically like what went on but they
can also say like
yeah i don't understand you know this
specific issue
can you you know get me up to speed um i
would like to have a disclaimer for my
mom and dad what's coming out of my
mouth
is coming out through love also if
they're watching this please stop
watching this
my parents are very close-minded and
conservative and there have been fights
as in daniel's family i feel like in my
household my opinion is not valid
and it will never be valid as long as i
live i don't i don't want to be quiet
about the things and i want to speak up
and share my opinion but
when it comes to that my parents will
yell at me they'll get mad at me
and we'll get into like such large
arguments it's even gotten to the point
of one time where i've gotten into
arguments my parents like you're gonna
have to move out if you don't like agree
with these things and it's like i
understand what you're saying all but
you're telling me that if i don't do
what you're saying what you think is
correct i'm not allowed to think what i
think is correct because what you think
is correct is concrete
it's kind of similar but different like
i've i'm actually grateful
that my parents and i have different
political opinions because i think it's
kind of forced me to
try and see the other side and try to
understand why they think a certain way
sometimes those disagreements are
fundamental to your identity
like they say a lot about how you look
at the world how you treat
other people and it's hard to separate
that i don't want to be friends with
someone who thinks that
like people who are poor or unhoused
people are do that because it's their
choice because that's a fundamental
disagreement with what i believe
that's fair but also family i feel like
is different
they're immigrants um they didn't there
are certain issues that they won't
you know fully understand yes it would
be nice if they try to
it's very different with it like friends
or like your parents exactly
yes i agree 100 with daniel my parents
came from romania
it was communist at that point so their
views on the world are not going to be
the same as everyone's as like
they were you know so it changes because
where you come from is so different from
america
i have felt depressed three
two one go
there there are a lot of points where it
is romanticized and i think that's a
that's a con it's a difficult struggle
and also i think like within like the
black community there's
there also is just not a lot of
attention to mental health at all
obviously there's points where i feel
flustered and i feel like oh like
everything's crumbling around me
and that's like a very common human
thing people want to talk about how
depressed they are
until you're like hey i haven't taken a
shower in four weeks and i can't get out
of bed and i haven't been eating food
and they're like ew that's gross it's
like that's what depression is
especially with our generation what ends
up happening is that
some small thing happens and we're
depressed the term is just used so
loosely
when you say comments like that it takes
away the power in a sense from like
people that actually are seeking help
so i'm about to have a really vulnerable
moment with y'all
so my whole life i have been so bullied
and words hurt so much
and six months ago i almost took my life
because of like
like words um they have this uh effect
on you and sometimes you can't talk to
people about it
and my friend's mom posted
if you need to talk to someone to call
this number and i talked to them
and i spoke to them on the phone for two
hours by myself at nighttime
and if it wasn't for her just doing that
i feel like i wouldn't have been here
today
can i give you a hug yeah it's okay
yeah thanks for sharing that oh thank
you that takes a lot of guts to speak up
about it
my whole life i've wanted to
show kindness through me and i hope that
i do
show kindness to others because i don't
want other people
to feel the same way i felt because if i
can help
someone feel that smile or that joy
for me it would make it would mean
everything to me because it means that
i'm fighting what other people
did to me i don't really like it when
people like compare their depressions
because like
you know saying like someone else is not
depressed because you don't really know
what they like feel
but i'm really glad that people are like
talking about it now and that we can
all like bond over it i'm truly thinking
that like
the pressure that's put on our
generation with social media is what
like
causes it um but yeah i'm really glad
that like people talk about it so we
have resources and stuff
i am optimistic about the future
three two one
go
personally it's in my nature to not be
optimistic because i think a lot of
people in our generation are very
nihilistic i try not to like
view it like that because it's very like
deterministic like
well the world's going to hell like we
can't do anything
and if you believe that then like you're
not
fighting for like a better world and
you're not fighting for change
i'm very much with sarah on the point
where our generation is very cynical
very nihilistic we
like to just like assume that things
can't be fixed because
in the past they just never were i don't
know i think i'm very optimistic for the
future because i believe
as we become more educated and we have
more resources to certain things and
information
we can do great things but we just have
to believe that we can or else it won't
happen
now i'm feeling sad about saying someone
disagree i just was thinking about this
in like the climate perspective
and like social media how it's been used
so negatively
um when i think about those two major
things
i can't see it stopping anywhere it's a
little unimaginable it's like
yeah no like i want to be positive of
course and i want the change to happen
but like
like where does it start i try to be
positive and i try to
i always say like if there's something
you don't like we can work on it and fix
it and i think that this generation in
particular is really good at that like
gen z is crazy like we
get things done the impact we've had
with like tick tock even like
yeah we we've changed a lot of things i
feel like
we have come far as a society but
doesn't mean i'm also not disappointed
in our society
there's so many things that we've gotten
to like build upon as a society and
people are growing upon as a society
and you know what after like meeting you
guys today i'm not gonna lie i feel like
there's hope on a more societal point of
view i feel very good that like change
will occur
whether we like it or not that's just
how society as we progress that is
officially a wrap great job
[Applause]
does that be like a moment